70 من اصل 200 من اعضاء مجلس النواب صوتوا
في بنغازي على ايقاف رئيس الحكومه المكلفه
من المجلس نفسه فتحي بشاغه واحالته الى
التحقيق في جلسه لم يشاهد الليبيون
مداولاتها مصادر برلمانيه قالت ان التقرير
للجنه الشؤون الرقابيه اوصى باحاله بشغه
الى التحقيق على خلفيه صرف ميزانيه منحت
لحكومته في وقت سابق لم يعلق بشاغا او اي
من اعضاء حكومته على القرار الذي تردد
صداه في طرابلس الا ان رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله خالد المشري وصفه بالقرار العبثي
الذي صدر بطريقه مريبه بعد تكليف باشاغا
بتشكيل حكومته بصوره غير شفافه للاسف
الشديد مجلس النواب لا يسال يعني لا يمارس
الامور السياسيه بطريقه مؤسسيه
هناك
اشياء شخصيه تدخل في هذا الموضوع مصالح
انيه انانيه
ضروره انها تتحقق هذه المصالح وهم يبحثون
عن تحقيق هذه المصالح متى ما وجدوا هذه
المصالح فهم يمشوا في اتجاه معين متى ما
يجد ان هذه المصالح لا تتحقق يوقف التعامل
مع الشخص ويبعدوه ويعزوه وهناك من يرى ان
ما حدث يمهد لانهاء حكومه بشاغه وايجاد
تفاهمات مع اطراف الازمه في شرق ليبيا
لتعديل حكومه عبد الحميد الدبيبه
واستمرارها هنا هناك اشكاليات داخل مجلس
النواب واشكاليات ايضا ماديه في المنطقه
الشرقيه وحسب ما يقال بان بشغه اتته اموال
وتم صرفها ولا يعلم بها مجلس النواب
فبالتالي هذه واحده من الاشكاليات قبل
اكثر من عام وبعد الانقسام السياسي اعلن
مجلس النواب الليبي تكليف فتح بشاغا
برئاسه حكومه ضمت في صفوفها
موالينا للواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ولم
تستطع دخول العاصمه طرابلس رغم خوضها
مواجهات مسلحه لتحقيق ذلك قد يلقي ايقاف
فتح باشا بظلاله على ما توصف بالتوافقات
بين اطراف الازمه السياسيه في شرق ليبيا
وغربها وقد يزعزع الثقه في اي توافقات
مستقبليه بين القاده السياسيين فهو يمثل
طيفا سياسيا يسعى ان يكون شريكا في حكم
البلاد وادارتها احمد خليفه الجزيره
طرابلس